ils font maintenant partie du décor
quand justin trudeau fait campagne en
ontario
les manifestants qui tentent de barrer
la route à l'autobus libéral
hydro poussée des bénévoles qui n'avait
à bolton qu'une petite corde pour les
retenir l'événement ce soir là avait
d'ailleurs été annulés
à newmarket en banlieue de toronto
justin trudeau a vu sur notre coeur 1
sec les protestataires il a attendu
plusieurs minutes avant de décider de
sortie je pars kull
c'est désolant de voir cette minorité
frustré cette ces gens marginalisés
c'est cette petite fraction de notre
population qui croît pas dans la science
menacé de nous ramener en arrière
mais en s'aventurant dans ce genre de
foule le chef libéral métier la sécurité
et surtout celle de son équipe en danger
on a pris la décision ensemble et la grc
a fait partie des discussions que si on
le faisait d'une certaine façon en
minimise l jusqu'à un niveau acceptable
les risques de la situation
chef du npd a lui aussi été confronté à
quelques manifestants ont continué de
reçu des menaces
et c'est un problème mais campagne
électorale est toujours leur lot de
protestataires mais de cette ampleur
c'est assez inusité croit cet ancien
sous commissaire de la grc moi
personnellement jamais été témoin
il rappelle qu'en 2019 le greffier du
conseil privé avait déclaré craint pour
la vie de certains politiciens la raison
du discours public plus polarisé avec
sanitaires on vit présentement et tous y
en tôle et disco consommant la
vaccination contre vie des gens qui sont
pas en faveur de cela évidemment ça crée
une atmosphère qui est plutôt explosif
d'ailleurs de nombreux manifestants
s'identifient comme sympathisant du
parti populaire du canada nordine them
to go m protoss chef maxime bernier leur
demande de rester pacifiques mais défend
leur droit de s'exprimer d abdoulaye
tout exprès de point de vue
des manifestants ont même lancé des
petit rush vers justin trudeau c'est une
situation très délicate des personnes
chargées de la protection du premier
ministre font une protection très
rapprochées au tour du premier ministre
pour éviter justement que un résidu avec
des mauvaises intentions plus aussi trop
avoir
été logique même s'il ya un enjeu de
sécurité le chef libéral n'était pas
servir de la présence de ces
manifestants comme levier politique une
façon pour lui de renforcer son message
sur la vaccination obligatoire si leurs
forfaits radio-canada à wayne en ontario